hello everyone my name is emily and this
is some sub a channel all about how to
survive in the online jungle
so today's video is going to be a little
bit different to usual i'm not going to
tell you how to delete your social media
account or how to launder millions of
dollars with the help of nfts because
well we've already talked about that
today actually i'm asking you to immerse
yourself in the world of art more
specifically vintage art and join me as
i conduct a small experiment with the
help of neural networks and modern
technologies we'll try to revive the
early beauties of the last century so
that they literally emerge from pinup
posters and appear before you on the
screen will a neural network having only
a drawing at its disposal be able to
turn our 2d illustrations into a moving
image of a real person to help us
evaluate the work of artificial
intelligence we'll compare the results
to real-life photos of these pin-up
girls now personally i'm ready to go
back in time and look into the eyes of
our reincarnated pin-up girls so let's
go
[Music]
now the term pinup covers a wide range
of mediums it can refer to drawings
paintings and other illustrations as
well as photographs
but why did i decide to experiment with
pin-up images well firstly they're very
aesthetically pleasing and secondly
because of the historical significance
of these images after all it was such
posters that helped win the second world
war
and i'm not exaggerating at all
pinups first became popular around the
time that the united states joined the
second world war at the end of 1941 when
they were used to raise the morale of
conscripts the way they created these
pin-up illustrations was that first they
took a photo of the model in the
required pose and then based on this
photograph they created a colorful
illustration
drawings of pretty girls were placed on
the covers of magazines on posts in
cinemas used to advertise a variety of
products and they also decorated
military equipment
soldiers painted these fictional
beauties on their combat vehicles as
well as their wives or famous movie
actresses
this kind of art even got its name nozar
because of the appearance of these
drawings on combat aircraft or more
specifically the nose of the aircraft
now it's important to note that the
pin-up is provocative but not vulgar
moderate nudity of the model was as a
rule accidental a gust of wind for
example could inadvertently lift the
dress and expose the legs as i've
already said the basis of the drawing
was a photograph of the model and
usually it was a famous actress or
actors that then became models
and yes male pinups did also exist but
it was a lot less popular
one of the very first and most popular
pinup girls was betty grable whose
poster in the lockers of soldiers during
world war ii
later this picture was included by life
magazine in the list of 100 photos that
changed the world with the help of
neural networks we were able to revive
one of the pinup posters this is an
advertisement for cigarettes released in
1944
a little magic and
[Music]
[Music]
during her career betty was able to earn
over three million dollars she featured
in 42 films that were released during
the 1930s and 40s and brought in more
than a hundred million dollars
grabel even has her own star on the
hollywood walk of fame
her legs were insured by the british
company lloyds of london for one million
dollars
as graber herself said there are two
reasons for my success and i stand on
both
but in addition to beautiful legs graber
was the owner of an incredibly beautiful
smile
now this gorgeous lady is betty brosma
she started her career at the age of 13
and has won more than 50 beauty contests
there are currently more than 150
magazines with her photos alone
her most striking feature was a very
narrow waist only about 46 centimeters
betty brosma became the first model who
had all the rights to her photos she
received a cut every time her photo was
published
marilyn monroe only became a commercial
phenomenon after 1955.
and since 1948 and throughout the 50s
betty was considered the standard of
female beauty
all professional women at that time
looked up to her and tried to imitate
her look some even more corsets to
emphasize their figure
by the way the secret of brosnah was
actually quite simple she loved sports
and carefully monitored her physical
activity and nutrition in the late 1960s
the owner of the wasp waste as it was
sometimes referred to met the
bodybuilder arnold schwarzenegger the
young people became friends and began to
work together to popularize fitness
this year brosna will be 86 years old
and she still looks amazing to go back
to the past for a while let's repeat the
trick with neural networks and bring
this betty brosman poster to life
this is probably one of the most famous
photos of betty from which perhaps a
dozen pieces of art were made in it
rosemary flaunts her famous tiny waist
but right now we are more interested in
her face
[Music]
so
[Music]
neural networks have done a good job i
think this animation really shows us
what betty brosmer looked like more than
half a century ago now if arnold
schwarzenegger happens to be watching
this video then ani you should write in
the comments how successful our
experiment was remembering the 40s of
the last century it would be a mistake
not to mention the beautiful ava gardner
the owner of the face of an angel and
the body of a goddess as the american
actress and singer was once described
was one of the brightest hollywood stars
of the 40s and 50s
her many achievements included an
academy award nomination in 1953 a bafta
award as well as a best actress award
and a golden globe in 1964.
now garner also had an unsurpassed sense
of style which had a huge impact on
fashion trends in post-war america and
beyond
in a classic rags-to-riches story an
ordinary farm girl from north carolina
became an icon of hollywood
as a basis for the live photo we took
one of the posters for the film that
gardner featured in and here's what
happened
[Music]
[Music]
well what do you think did the neural
network do a good job in any case i
enjoyed this little experiment
with the help of neural networks the
system analyzes the image highlights and
improves the face and then adds
animation to it
a few minutes and we already have the
opportunity to step back into the past
today we've shown you just one of the
capabilities of neural networks you can
also experiment with similar programs
yourself and share your opinion about
the work of artificial intelligence in
the comments what artwork or images
would you like to bring to life
anyway thanks for tuning in today guys
this was emily with some sub i'll be
waiting for you on our next tour of the
online jungle
[Music]
you